the hunt is on in the Philippines drug
dealers addicts but also innocent
citizens thousands of people have been
killed since firebrand president rodrigo
duterte started his uncompromising war
on drugs when he took office at the end
of June the charity keeps shocking the
world with fresh calls to kill even more
and he doesn't shy away from drastic
comparisons three million Jews know
there is three million on the other hand
his policies have led some 700,000 drug
users to surrender to the authorities
many are now overcrowding prisons and
rehabilitation facilities afraid for
their lives but Tutera is also making
waves on the diplomatic front he hurls
frequent insults beat against the UN the
EU or the United States he had this to
say about President Barack Obama before
a regional summit in September of
creator concern especially to the US is
the proclamation of what the Philippine
president calls an independent foreign
policy protector wants to rely less on
the u.s. in part because of Western
criticism of his war on drugs eventually
I might in my turn in my time I will
break up with America I would rather go
to Russia and to China
at least even if we do not agree with
their ideology
we have respect for the people the
turtle hopes to come to terms with
Beijing on the issue of the South China
Sea China claims most of it as part of
its own territory a claim hotly
contested by the Philippines as well as
its neighbors on the domestic front it's
not only the war on drugs he's put his
focus on the Teta has rekindled peace
talks with Maoist rebels in the south of
the country many hope Tutera can finally
accomplish what five presidents before
him failed to achieve and Asia's
longest-running communist insurgency